dès la 10 boumédiène cette mobilisation
vous en attendez quoi
oui non il n'y a pas plus de monde les
manifestations vont donc la préfecture
de mystère l'intérieur annonce 200 mille
personnes la semaine dernière
je pense qu'un a beaucoup plus mais
comme d'habitude et minimise on espérait
qu'il ya beaucoup plus on espérer que
comme vous avez pu le voir dans
plusieurs cortèges il ya même des
personnes qui sont fait vacciner qui
soutiennent le mouvement de contestation
d'obligations dupas sanitaire parce
qu'il y va de la liberté de chacun il
n'y pas de valeur fondamentale égalité
fraternité liberté que nous devons
préserver il faut vraiment inacceptable
et trouver ce stratagème pour pouvoir
nous nous obliger à obliger à accepter
les personnes dans les établissements et
commerces les cafés les bars des
restaurants des clubs de sport surtout
avec l'obligation d'être vaccinés ou
d'avoir un passage avec leurs codes au
mieux c'est absolument inacceptable
qu'on demande la république et nous
devons absolument rester mobilisés nous
rejoignons la manifestation il ya deux
manifestations qui se sont organisés sur
la ville de lyon des résistances et nous
espérons que tu as beaucoup beaucoup de
concitoyens mobilité c'est les valeurs
de la république de ne pas fou et de
déstabiliser aujourd'hui c'est le
passage vers demain quelques ce sera
avec monsieur m'a répondu c'est
absolument inacceptable de plus comme le
dit si bien le ministère de la santé le
vérin le virus est d'angers l'inconnu on
a pu voir en israël ou dans d'autres
pays en angleterre donc la majorité de
la population qui est vacciné et on
passe à une troisième victime nation
c'est à dire que il y a des failles
c'est à dire que le vaccin n'est pas
infaillible armement de gens qui sont
vaccinés qui tombent malades
le gouvernement a raison
regrettons également profondément que le
conseil constitutionnel conseil des
sages n'est pas retoqué cette décision
injuste aurait dû annuler faire abroger
cette décision notamment aussi d'obliger
les le corps médical à se soigner
on parle aussi nous entends commerçants
pas tous les marchés de nous faire
vacciner
oui je vais passer d'abord la parole à
jacques meyer on parlera après justement
de la situation des commerçants avec
vous monsieur meyer cette mobilisation
qui manifestement à prendre de l'ampleur
quelle lecture en faites vous il est
évident que c'est une manifestation
contre le gouvernement et contre le
président de la république qui a perdu
toute crédibilité
au-delà de la question je dirais du pass
sanitaire qui est un problème réel et
sur lequel je voudrais souligner que le
conseil constitutionnel il y a mis les
formes pour adopter le pass sanitaire il
ya plus de soixante attendus ou
considérant qu'ils traitent de la
question et qui montre bien qu'il y a
hilale ses propres réserves
il n'a pas je dirais béni le pass
sanitaires sans y mettre des limites
notamment des limites dans le temps ce
qui prouve bien qu'il est mal à l'aise
le conseil constitutionnel et qu'il y a
effectivement comme cela vient d'être
souligné une rupture d'égalité alors
c'est l'antichambre de la vaccination
pour tous il y a en france beaucoup de
vaccins qui sont obligatoires notamment
pour les enfants dans les crèches les
écoles
ce qui est certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui
on constate quoi on constate une levée
de boucliers contre le gouvernement
alors bien sûr c'est pas la majorité des
procès mais c'est une forte opposition
donc pour moi c'est une manifestation
éminemment politique de gens qui ont nom
part dans l'expression ras-le-bol de
gens qui jugent que le gouvernement et
que le président de la république en
particulier a perdu sa crédibilité et
qu'il souhaite avoir une autre politique
cela étant
cela étant il est évident que la seule
solution c'est la vaccination
on va se tromper on peut être contre 6
contre cela il n'en demeure pas moins
que le vaccin que le fameux delta il est
là et que je crois que il est urgent que
les français prennent conscience qu'il
est dans leur intérêt individuel et
collectif de se vacciner
cela étant aussi le pass sanitaire
fausse de multiples problèmes et je
comprends je dirais la levée de
boucliers de certains de nos
compatriotes qui estime que le pass
sanitaire est effectivement une rupture
d'égalité mais le gouvernement n'a pas
voulu aller jusqu'à la vaccination
obligatoire et se retrouve dans un
compromis bancal qui pose des problèmes
et j'en veux pour preuve que le conseil
constitutionnel lui-même a essayé de
l'encadrer le maximum a annulé un
certain nombre de dispositions notamment
pour les salariés en cdd ou en cdi et en
ce qui concerne aussi les commerces et
les grandes surfaces
donc on voit bien qu'on est dans un
domaine extrêmement complexe et délicat
alors adelaziz boumédiène vous êtes
commerçant et en tant que commerçant
l'application ne se passa ni terre sa
mise en place le gouvernement at il
donné un des indications c'est que
gabriel gabriela talent a parlé d'une
semaine de rodage beaucoup pensent que
ce n'est pas suffisant
oui absolument ce n'est pas suffisant et
on est un peuple et de cour vous avez on
parle d'une unité collective on s'y
dirige doucement qui est plus de 60% de
la population de 60 % de la population
et déjà été entièrement donc on est on
est en passe de l'obtenir cette immunité
collective mais je ne pense pas qu'on va
obliger les citoyens à se vacciner ou à
avoir un passé militaire voire café
pense pas que c'est la solution et comme
vous pouvez le voir dans con je parlais
tout à l'heure la baptisation est une
solution mais la bâtisse n'est pas la
solution on ne connaît pas ambre l2 le
vrai fondement du de ce virus
on s'épanche se dirige aujourd'hui on a
le le le variant indien demain on aura
rien tania on aura chaque fois des
parias chaque fois faudra rajouter un
autre vaccin
donc là on conseille ou une troisième
activation ou va-t-on 4e 5e
continuellement comme cela on va attiser
la vaccination
ça doit pas être la seule solution c'est
pour ça qu'on ne pouvons pas obliger nos
compatriotes le peuple de france a
obligé de se vacciner
je pense que c'est une très mauvaise
solution on devrait laisser le libre à
chacun là on rejoint la manifestation
compatriotes nous rejoint qui sont
vaccinés et qui sont contre le pass and
i terre parce que le sanitaire et tin
est un peu un déni on peut pas nous
obliger à nous vacciner vernement
devrait être souvenu il ya quelques
années la grippe aviaire
on a dépensé des sommes colossales
acheter des vaccins qu'on a dû par la
suite jeté des poubelles qu'on devrait
être un peu plus prudent et on devrait
aller avec le vaccin vaccin est une
solution
le vaccin n'est pas la seule solution
est le maintien n'est pas la solution on
a pu le voir dans plusieurs pays tu vas
signer et le vénus ou bien parce qu'il
ya des variantes et un virus inconnu
c'est un virus inconnu qu'on connaît pas
qu'on ne maîtrise pas
donc je ne pense pas qu'on doit aller
déjà mère un clivage on va vers un
clivage et c'est très mauvais on doit
être uni le peuple de france
si on française doit être dans un même
combat la relation qu'on s'affaire
abdelaziz boumédiène je suis désolé on
est pressé par le temps jacques myard
j'ai juste vous posez
question le gouvernement la firme se
passe sanitaire c'est pour freiner la
propagation du virus parmi deux français
qui refusent se passe on l'a dit il ya
des vaccinés il ya aussi ceux qui ne
croient pas aux motivations du
gouvernement jacques myard pourquoi y at
il autant de défiance puis écoutez je
crois que ça tient de les incohérences
de la politique gouvernementale en
matière de lutte contre le virus
il ya eu la sphère des masses il fallait
pas voter des basses ensuite le
président la république a dit lui-même
qui ne rendraient pas le vaccin
obligatoire
et puis on voit bien aujourd'hui avec le
pain sanitaires il veut contraindre les
conseils à se vacciner
moi je suis pour la vaccination je crois
que notre ami beauvaisienne fait une
erreur car il y à de multiples vaccins
qui sont obligatoires en france
notamment pour les enfants
mais ce qui est certain c'est que c'est
cette incohérence ses tergiversations
permanente du gouvernement a créé bien
sûr les interrogations des français et
il y a des doutes mais il y aura
toujours des doutes il peut y avoir des
accidents malheureusement au moment de
la vaccination mais ça peut arriver à
n'importe quel la vaccination la grippe
moi je me suis fait vacciner contre la
grippe de manière régulière
il ya parfois des dératés m'exprimer
ainsi
aujourd'hui on a quand même l'expérience
de multiples vaccination dans le monde
avec un minimum je lis bien un minimum
de cas douloureux donc ce qui est en
cause aujourd'hui c'est qu'effectivement
si on a deux situations de français ceux
qui sont vaccinés les ce qu'il refuse et
qui refusent de passes sanitaires ça va
créer des problèmes et des tensions
c'est ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui dans
la rue mais malheureusement je le répète
c'est le gouvernement qui en est
grandement
le responsable parce que il a tergiversé
à ce qu'il a agi trop tard et qu'il
aurait dû aller au bout de la logique à
savoir il n'y a pas d'autre solution que
la vaccination c'est là où il ya un
problème c'est un problème de
crédibilité gouvernementale qui vient
après de multiples bévues après des
phrases maladroites du président de la
république qui aujourd'hui semble être
un gourou n'est ce pas ils vous donnent
des leçons dépit d'une au logis du haut
de sa stature de jupiter ce n'est pas
acceptable
il faut comprendre pourquoi les français
sont réfractaires sur certains points
c'est par la pédagogie il faut agir et
aussi arriver à une solution qui nous
permette d'atteindre l'immunité
collective
il n'y a pas 36 solutions c'est
d'inviter nos concitoyens à se vacciner
je sais que certains refusent mais je
pense que dans leur grande sagesse
ils y viendront jacques mignard merci à
vous je rappelle que vous êtes mer et
l'air de maisons laffitte ancien député
avec vous abdelaziz boumédiène vous êtes
président de l'association des
commerçants indépendants les marchés de
france merci à vous deux messieurs
d'avoir été en direct avec nous sur rt
france